bili Eilish rips a nylon Germany a new
one
following the reveal of an unauthorized
cover earlier this week dude there's a
thing bro here's the image that has the
bad guy singer all riled up as you can
see Billy is depicted as a bald
shirtless robot the foreign mags shared
the pic to Instagram and that's where
all hell let loose because apparently
the 17 year old was totally shook by the
image I don't even know what Billy hit
up the comments section with some choice
four-letter words writing quote what the
[ __ ] is this the team went on to explain
that neither she nor her team had been
approached about the cover and it wasn't
even a real pic of her Billy added
you're gonna make a picture of me
shirtless that's not real at 17 and make
it the cover even if the picture was
supposed to look like some robot version
of me I did not consent in any way then
Billy did what you do when you're really
trying to make a point activating the
caps lock button and you're gonna remove
all my fin hair boo to you nothing says
I'm mad like all caps and if nylon
Germany still didn't get the message she
wrapped up her point with a loaded
middle finger emoji that's all I'd say
to be honest with you well it turns out
the mag heard Billy loud and clear and
responded to her in the comment section
saying they never intended to confuse or
insult Billy or her fans and explaining
it was part of a series highlighting the
power of digital prodigy artists Billy's
cover is one of multiple cover stars for
the September issue of the mag I never
want the world to know everything about
me
I mean that's why I wear big baggy
clothes nobody can have an opinion
because they haven't seen what's
underneath you know in the past Billy
has explained she prefers to wear
oversized clothes to keep a part of
herself a mystery from the public and in
March she told ET her style is an
important creative outlet for her how in
general would you describe your style I
like to be judged so I wanna I want to
see heads look up does that happen to
you when you walk down the street are
people coming up to you asking about
your style is it weird that people are
so intrigued and interested it's it's
really sick it's kind of exactly what I
would want people to care about you know
yeah like I don't know the things that
the people sort of know me for are all
the things I want to be known for if
that makes sense because style has
always been something I care about
you know visuals and videos and
you know designs and stuff is also
something and you know those are the
things people sort of asked me about or
company about which i think is really
grateful for that
I don't blame Billy for being all fired
up and I love that she isn't afraid to
stand up for herself
of course when Billy has something to
say et will be right here to tell you
all about it so make sure to come on
back until then I'm Hallie Stevens bye
for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]